she did not understand the assignment
hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be reviewing jillian michael's
take on intuitive eating but first let
me tell you about my sponsor billbar so
i know it's the new year new you season
which is a saying i hate but guys i have
been eating these belt bars for over a
year now and i'm not going to be doing
anything differently in 2022. let me
tell you i mean if you have not yet
hopped on this train get on it these
bars are so unlike any other protein bar
i've ever tried because they actually
taste
like a candy bar like no chalky powdery
mealy texture here and there are so many
fun flavors so today i'm busting into a
new one for me
coconut brownie chunk
hello
i feel like this is a very coconut
brownie chunk sweater right like we're
matching this is a mood right here
oh yeah
the coconut
that's next level she's so good oh my
goodness this is a favorite i'm excited
about the whole pack
okay and you guys know what i say about
the zero gill thing unless you stole
them from a baby all foods are zero
guilt these are one of my all-time
favorite bedtime snacks or i use them on
oatmeal to really bump the satiety
factor and turn them into one of my
hunger crushing combos so if you want to
give these a try check out the link in
the description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and of course be sure to read my
disclaimer including a trigger warning i
mean jillian isn't known to sugarcoat
diet advice so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are new here
welcome please don't forget to subscribe
to this channel ring that bell and also
follow me over on instagram and tick
tock at abby's kitchen also if you
missed my what i eat in a day review on
jillian you can check that out right
here but you guys asked for another
jillian video since there's just so much
problematic content to unpack so today
we're going to be reviewing her hot take
on intuitive eating and yes your girl's
already tired don't take my word for it
so they're
can you see it
no you can't all right the ten
principles of intuitive eating okay so
not to be
i mean i know we're all super busy but
if you're gonna make a whole youtube
video criticizing intuitive eating maybe
like pick up the book like that website
gives a two-line summary which captures
none of the nuance that is actually
required to grasp the intuitive eating
concept even my whole video series which
has like 45 minutes per video per
principal is just the jumping off point
like i just don't love the whole like
you diet mentality like i i just this is
where we sort of it's like death
protests too much you know what i mean
it's like healthy at any size
i love being a size 16. i mean again
like i don't care if somebody is a size
16 it doesn't mean i don't love them
care about them feel their worthy or
deserving but it does mean they're not
healthy and if you really care about
somebody you want them to be healthy so
this kind of mentality is like little
angry
first of all
i'm pretty sure the reason we need to
get angry at diet culture is because of
people like jillian but also why call
out that someone couldn't possibly love
being a size 16 and then like back pedal
to insist you don't care if someone's a
size 16 but then yeah you do because you
care about their health
mess but also just gotta say someone's
dress size cannot possibly tell us if
that person is metabolically healthy so
this is a pretty ignorant point next if
you're trying to lose weight you can
keep your body biologically fed with
proper foods
on
i mean as low as 1200 which i've said is
the absolute floor especially if you are
obese 1400 1600 i mean most people
shouldn't really most women especially
women like higher in age shouldn't
really be eating over 1600 calories a
day it's too much oxidative stress our
metabolism isn't that fast and we just
don't need that much food i'm sorry
did she just say that we should be
eating as little as 1200 calories is
this the person who is responsible for
the hundreds of dms i get every single
day from young girls telling me that
they've been told to only eat 1200
calories because folks that's what my 15
month old eats and he's literally as big
as my arm when it comes to actual adults
research suggests that reducing calories
this low can result in significant
metabolic suppression which in turn
actually makes it harder to maintain
weight loss and if we put weight loss
aside
it's also really hard to get the basic
nutrients that we need when we're eating
like a 30 pound toddler one study found
that obese folks on low calorie diets
like this were almost always
micronutrient deficient and another
study found that it took on average over
3 000 calories to meet most of our
micronutrient needs for the day now
balancing micronutrients and
macronutrients and calories is obviously
a challenge with weight loss but we
actually should be focused on finding
ways to eat more not less don't let
yourself get overly hungry totally legit
but if you're trying to lose weight guys
the whole point is is to actually not
eat adequate energy we create an energy
deficit so that your body goes to its
fat stores which is stored energy
jillian did not understand the
assignment i'm not sure why she's
responding to all of these principles
from a place of weight loss because the
authors of the intuitive eating
framework
are very clear that it's not a weight
loss diet in fact the principles
explicitly suggest putting intentional
weight loss on the back burner in order
to effectively harness your intuition
around food this is bad i mean i'm not
religious i have no idea what christ ate
at his last supper i don't think he
gorged himself but who knows i don't
even understand these references this is
just so intense and hostile what if i
said give yourself unconditional
permission to drink or smoke or spend
money you don't have no you don't get
unconditional permission to eat it's
called self-control balance because yes
if you do deprive yourself yeah the
pendulum will swing back the other way
so don't deprive yourself but don't go
hog wild either so
it's one thing to be open to learning
and acknowledge when you have no clue
what you're talking about but jillian is
discussing this as if she's an authority
on the
respect my topic
and that is confusing us
anyway jillian interprets giving
yourself unconditional permission to eat
to meaning eat all the things which i
think makes absolute sense for somebody
living in a perpetual state of
restriction and control this probably is
what would happen at first if she gave
herself unconditional permission to eat
there's almost always like a vacation
phase for long-term dieters when they
allow themselves to eat all the foods
that they've previously restricted
themselves on but over time for the vast
majority of people this novelty factor
wears off like it loses its power it's
knocked off its pedestal and you
actually gain better clarity on how
foods make you feel i know it's very
hard to imagine not wanting these foods
all the time but the best way that i can
describe it is when you're feeling sick
like even if it was your birthday and
there was like a decadent looking cake
there if you had a nasty flu you
probably would just feel like i don't
know eating soup and bread even if you
love cake there would probably be a
primal disinterest in that cake now
imagine being that in tune with your
primal needs every single day when you
know you can have cake sometimes you
just won't want cake obviously this is a
marathon not a sprint and you kind of
have to like trust the process i would
say that this shift to not wanting cake
all day will not happen overnight if
you've always restricted cake but it's
worth committing to the journey
[Music]
now as for jillian's approach to what
she calls balance i gotta call out this
bs balance is not about letting yourself
have a candy bar but only under the
condition that you work out harder and
eat less the next day to make up for it
that's what we call punishment and it's
actually the exact opposite of intuitive
eating so i guess i'm okay with this one
yeah don't beat yourself up don't do
that it doesn't serve a purpose and if
you do remember that it just means you
believe you're capable of more okay so
jillian seemingly agrees with the
concept of challenging the food police
but only under certain restrained
circumstances which kinda is the theme
of her review what i'm hearing when she
says we are capable of more is that
you're good if you can only eat one
slice of cake as long as it fits within
the 80 20 rule but if you ate more than
that well you need to do better this is
exactly what the food police does like
it's that internal voice that triggers
feelings of guilt and shame when you
break your arbitrary rules challenging
the food police means embracing food
neutrality and trading in those feelings
of guilt and shame for kindness
self-compassion and trust given
jillian's history of militant and rigid
training though the only way you're
coming off this damn treadmill is if you
die on it i'm really not surprised she
missed the bar on this one discover the
satisfaction fact i love this agree you
should enjoy your food i'm totally with
this i'm not
of the ilk that food is just fuel um i
think you should enjoy your food okay
cool so i feel like this is a pretty
easy one to get on board with but given
what i've learned about jillian from my
last review i can't help but wonder if
satisfaction is only permitted under
certain conditions like you know being
organic or only having one bite and even
then if you recall it seemed like she
was ashamed like she was shaming herself
when she chose peanut butter over almond
butter even though she said it wasn't as
healthy you know it's very hard to find
true satisfaction in food when you're so
distracted by ritual and punishing
regime when we override our physical
signals of fullness it's because
something else is happening up here
pause think it through you know by
taking a minute and questioning yourself
how do i feel am i full am i really
hungry do i have cravings you're
shifting the part of your brain from
impulse and emotion to reason if we keep
eating how are we going to feel better
or worse like heartburn kind of
disappointed in ourselves which by the
way i don't think there's anything wrong
with that we can be disappointed in
ourselves if we know we could do better
is it just me or is this just a really
condescending way to describe willpower
it's about drive it's about power we
stay hungry we devour but can somebody
please tell jillian that you can't
really necessarily logic your way out of
hunger as it's actually a primal
physical signal now what is even more
confusing here is that while critiquing
this tenant she actually just reiterates
it like it's really about checking in
with yourself throughout the meal and
collecting data about how we feel the
only confusion here is that jillian sees
this as an opportunity to judge yourself
and feel disappointed in yourself if you
choose to eat more when in fact if we
feel heartburn and bloated after maybe
having too many slices of pizza we could
take note of that the next time with
compassion and awareness and yes if we
override our feelings of fullness
consistently we can also acknowledge hey
maybe we need to address the root of the
problem but if you continue to severely
restrict food will always be seen as a
reward in hard times it will always be
abused and where's the line between
disappointed and beating yourself up
letting go of that disappointment and
moral judgment is the first step in
helping to get back in tune with your
true hunger and fullness cues so that
you can eat mostly to meet physical
needs we overeat or we have issues with
food and utilize food as a coping
mechanism which i myself do why do you
think i'm in this business because i had
to battle my own demons as a kid so i
understand it and i understand it
without judgment we all have crutches
for some of us it's food they can't just
be like yo don't eat when you're angry
it doesn't that's like ridiculous like
it takes work years of working on
yourself so while this is great it's not
as simple as this but it is definitely
crucial to work on if you utilize food
as a coping mechanism or a defense
mechanism okay i'm glad to see that
jillian can at least acknowledge that
there exists an emotional component to
food and that it's not just like
calories in calories out and while i'm
not here to deny that it takes a lot
a lot of practice and patience and time
to disrupt emotional eating patterns
considering jillian has first-hand
experience with this i'm a little
surprised that she's so dismissive but
it feels like even when jillian agrees
with the principle she finds a way to
turn it into a rule intuitive eating is
actually about letting go of rules so
this principle isn't about never eating
when you're angry or happy or sad it's
not suggesting that you're doing
intuitive eating wrong if you eat a pint
of ice cream after a breakup feed your
face hole with flavors like tear salt
caramel it's simply about practicing
self-awareness self-introspection and
self-compassion without judgment when
you do eat that ice cream while at the
same time also trialling other
non-food-related mechanisms to see if
they serve you better for some it might
mean therapy as jillian suggests but for
others it might mean going for a walk
calling a friend or listening to some
relaxing music this is not a rule but an
invitation to ask yourself questions and
collect data for a future day all bodies
deserve dignity
agree uh
is this coming from the same woman who
said this are you gonna die
yes you are gonna die yes and you're
gonna feel bad no i won't i'll be so
proud you'll be my first casualty unless
you faint puke or die keep walking bend
your
knees or i'm going to break them with
this pole i hear her care
i don't care if your neck breaks in half
as long as you do it right i'll be happy
let's go i mean i will give jillian the
benefit of the doubt here and
acknowledge that this is really old
footage so perhaps she's evolved since
then are you sure about that and i will
also say that there is some evidence of
this in her podcast episode on intuitive
eating where she agrees that there is a
difference between health and aesthetic
goals and that you can be healthy with
cellulite stretch marks and body fat but
then i would ask where's the line for
you jillian because she also recently
called out lizzo for her body size you
cannot glorify
obesity that woman is 250 pounds good
for her and it's like
and automatically deduced that she must
have diabetes or that she can't possibly
be healthy in the body that she's in
what it sounds like to me is that
jillian agrees that all bodies deserve
dignity so long as it's talking about a
generally straight sized socially
acceptable body the most important thing
is you show up it might not be the most
effective form of fitness but it's a
heck of a lot better than nothing so i'm
kind of with this one too but i will not
negate that there are definitely forms
of fitness that will give you far better
results at a far faster faster pace and
if they don't intimidate you like why
not why not take why not get the great
benefits it's as if jillian can't
comprehend the idea that you can do
exercise without those weight loss
results and you can just move because it
feels good or that there are additional
non-calorie burning benefits like better
sleep and better energy strength mood
mobility and lower risk of chronic
disease why can't we focus the
conversation on that but again we've
seen her very militant and punitive
approach to exercise even going so far
as to basically glorify puking or
passing out never mind pushing through
when it very much does not feel good
this whole no pain no gain approach is
actually the complete opposite message
of this principle moving your body
should be a gift not a punishment
honestly western society is never going
to see improvements in population health
when the barriers to entry are just so
high but again it would probably be
off-brand for her to suggest anything
else
progress not perfection that's what
counts couldn't agree more however this
is also in direct opposition to the what
was it eat whatever the hell you want
unconditional permission to eat what i
don't like is it does negate some of the
basic science of losing weight oh
my f
i feel like i'm taking crazy pills this
is why jillian doesn't actually
understand intuitive eating at all it's
not all or nothing i know this is a huge
paradigm shift for a lot of us who have
been stuck in diet culture for so long
so i'm usually a lot more patient but
i'm just so annoyed that jillian doesn't
do her homework at all like it feels
like a moot point to even try to correct
her because the basis of her arguments
are all grounded in weight loss which
intuitive eating is not about but i will
try to make this as simple as possible
gentle nutrition you need to give
yourself permission to eat what you want
to help silence the noise that prevents
us from objectively collecting data on
how foods make us feel how does food
impact our energy levels mood sleep
digestion what we actually like etc this
is done without judgment moral
association or desire to manipulate our
body then once we've gone through all
these other principles only then can we
even start to think about gentle
nutrition in a way that's not going to
set us back and that contrary to
jillian's comment is in fact supported
by research
all that said it's quite clear that
jillian didn't do a lick of her own
research on intuitive eating and she
couldn't bring herself to put down her
damn weight loss tinted glasses to
attempt to see it for what it actually
is and that is a mind-body framework for
healing one's relationship with food and
it's really too bad because this lazy
youtube video of hers was a missed
opportunity to actually learn about an
evidence-based eating philosophy that
millions of people have benefited from
and after striking out once with her
podcast episode on this i mean you'd
think she would maybe hit the books
before going at it again here but she
basically has a lot of the same
unrehearsed uneducated remarks there but
until jillian can imagine a world where
health is about more than your weight i
do feel that the concept of intuitive
eating will just fall on deaf ears so
please if you guys are truly curious
about intuitive eating go by the book
which i'm gonna link below and watch my
beginners series here and on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on your thoughts and what you'd like to
see me cover next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]